now as 2021 draws to a close i think we're
all getting ready for Christmas but i want
to take a bit of an opportunity just to talk
through some of the highlights of this year
and some of the activities and actions that
we've been taking as a council to support our
residents and businesses now back in January we
announced that Sharley park leisure center and
the sports hall there was going to be used as
part of the vaccination rollout for coronavirus
and over the course of the year over the following
months we supported the NHS to deliver 60,000
vaccinations from that centre and i'm really
pleased that the North East Derbyshire District
council has been recognised for its contribution
to that fantastic vaccine rollout over the course
of the year and then in February we announced
that we were investing in our environmental health
service both in terms of helping with the public
health response to Covid but also to help us deal
with issues like fly tipping and environmental
crime and that's been a fantastic achievement
to be able to expand that service and really get
into some of those difficult issues that we face
in our rural districts in March we
have an absolutely fantastic month
in terms of government funding for this district
firstly we had the amazing announcement of 24.1
million pounds for clay cross as part of the Clay
Cross town deal then we also found out we'd have
been awarded 1.6 million pounds which we've topped
up with council the council's own funding to help
us deliver external wall insulation to over 400
properties around the district and particularly
those hard to heat homes and then finally we
also received a one million pound grant from the
government to help us improve Eckington leisure
centre and make it one of the most greenest and
most environmentally friendly leisure centres in
the whole of the region and that works almost due
for completion and hopefully will be reopened as
a pool very very soon now in April we elected our
35th chairman of the council Councillor Martin
Thacker and he launched his fundraising campaign
for Ashgate hospicecare and since then he's done
an absolute smattering of events throughout the
year and some fantastic fundraising activities
to raise vital funds for Ashgate hospicecare
now in may we held some a very difficult set
of elections because of code restrictions but
fortunately they ran very very smoothly and we had
lots of positive feedback from residents about the
whole process of voting and all the mitigations
that we put in place to help make voting and
that key part of being a democratic country
possible during the month of May and then in
June we worked with the government to support the
'kickstart scheme' to help give more young people
really valuable experience in work now in July we
signed the contract with Killamarsh parish council
as part of our 1.9 million takeover and
refurbishment of the sports centre there now works
already started and i'm really looking forward to
that that centre reopening in the next few months
and then also in the summer we had some
fantastic awards for some of our services
our health and safety team were awarded the
gold rosper award and our street scene team
were also awarded an APSE award for excellent
services so well done to both of those teams
now in September we launched together with
the other districts and county councils across
Derbyshire we launched our 'Vision Derbyshire
'business grants and advice to businesses now
in October we became the first council
in Derbyshire to implement mandatory CCTV
for taxis and private hire vehicles now
we think that will help make both the
passengers and the drivers themselves safer and
we're really proud to have been the first council
to have done that and also throughout October we
did a series of meet the council events and also
our armed forces covenant event to celebrate the
fantastic work of the armed forces in November we
delivered a jobs fair in Clay Cross to help local
people find local jobs and also our environmental
health team and did a fantastic job in seizing
and crushing a vehicle that was known to have been
involved in fly tipping in this area well done to
them and this month December we've announced our
involvement in the queen's green canopy scheme
which involves planting trees to help mark
the queen's platinum jubilee next year we're
really excited to be part of this amazing project
and that's just to name a few there's plenty more
on our website and on our social media channels
so please do check them out and find out more
about the fantastic things that we've been we've
been doing throughout this year now I know that
this time at the moment is a particularly anxious
time for some people with the concerns around the
omicron variant and the government's move to plan
b but i think it's absolutely vital that we all
continue to work together to follow the guidance
and follow those restrictions where necessary and
also make sure that we all get our vaccinations
done and go for our boosters when we're called
to do so we can continue to work together and
i'm sure we can defeat the virus and continue to
enjoy a good Christmas together all the same and
i hope everyone has a fantastic Christmas and a
very happy new year and look forward to 2022 when
i'm sure there's a lot more things we can
do as a council working with our residents
and our businesses and our community groups
and parish councils thank you very much.